[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara
guten abend zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem montag an meiner seite ist für
den sport norbert lehmann im tor von mir
und das sind die themen von heute
waren signale richtung moskau die g7
staaten haben der ukraine weitere
milliarden zugesagt und die nato will
ihre eingreiftruppe auf mehr als 300.000
soldaten massiv aufstocken
rekorde bei den austritten immer mehr
katholiken kehren ihrer kirche den
rücken auch solche die sich bislang
besonders engagiert haben
und auf 15 kilometern zum erfolg florian
wellbrock gewinnt bei der schwimm-wm
nach dem team titel auch einzel gold
bis zum winter so die hoffnung des
ukrainischen präsidenten bis zum winter
soll der krieg beendet sein wolodimir
seelands g war heute vormittag zu der
gipfelrunde in bayern zugeschaltet er
bekam die unterstützung der g7
zugesichert zudem sollen weitere
sanktionen den druck auf russland
erhöhen darüber hinaus ging es darum
lösungen zu finden für die drohende
hunger und energiekrise daniel punzen
über takt 2 dieses gipfels es ist eine
art speeddating generatoren ein
bilaterales treffen folgt aufs nächste
auf den indischen premier etwa der
argentinische präsident gespräche mit
den gastländern darunter auch indien
indonesien und senegal standen heute
nachmittag im mittelpunkt die g7 wollen
die verbindung zu diesen großen
schwellenländern stärken wirtschaftlich
im kampf gegen klimawandel und
krankheiten aber auch mit blick auf die
russische aggression auf den krieg in
der ukraine blicken wir aus
unterschiedlichen perspektiven das
wissen alle gerade deshalb ist es
wichtig dass wir miteinander darüber
sprechen und unsere jeweiligen
sichtweisen auch austauschen dass dieser
austausch also nicht dazu führte eben
jene perspektiven maßgeblich
anzugleichen dies hatte vorab schon die
außenministerin südafrika im gespräch
mit dem zdf angedeutet
die themen die zum krieg zwischen der
ukraine und russland geführt haben sind
gegenstand der globalen debatte seit
mehr als zehn jahren und afrika wurde
nie eingeladen um mit am tisch zu sein
um dies zu diskutieren
da kann man nicht jetzt sagen
entscheidet euch für diese richtung
wurde die andere immobilie war am
vormittag war der ukrainische präsident
zugeschaltet laut teilnehmerkreisen
forderte er massive hilfe für ein
kriegsende noch in diesem jahr von den
g7 die veröffentlichten im anschluss
eine erklärung man werde die ukraine
weiter unterstützen finanziell mit rund
28 milliarden euro zu dem humanitär
militärisch und diplomatisch und zwar so
die symbolträchtige formulierung so
lange wie nötig es nur text
deshalb ist auch klar im verhältnis zu
russland kann es kein zurück geben in
die zeit vor dem russischen überfall auf
die ukraine denn wenn die lage sich
verändert müssen auch wir uns verändern
das wissen alle sehr genau und alle g 7
staaten sind dazu auch bereit die
notwendigen entscheidungen zu treffen
unterdessen gab es auch heute zahlreiche
proteste meist eng eskortiert von der
polizei betreut das demonstrieren nur so
war es erlaubt 50 menschen durften
zumindest in sichtweite des schlosses
ihre kritik äußern diese chance haben
sich selbst legitimiert sie haben über
jahrzehnte lange politik gemacht die
nicht mensch und natur es sind viele
herausforderungen viele und vor allem
komplexe krisen die die sogenannten
schlossherrn die g7 staats und
regierungschefs wohl auf weit über
diesen gipfel hinaus fordern werden
drei der fünf eingeladenen
schwellenländer wie zb indien haben sich
bislang nicht an den sanktionen gegen
russland beteiligt rt wissen ist es
gelungen diese länder mit ins boot zu
holen also zumindest haben die g7 alle
register gezogen zum beispiel mit dem
infrastrukturpaket über 600 milliarden
dollar für konkrete projekte die eben
diesen schwellenländern helfen sollen
ihre wirtschaften zu modernisieren ohne
dass sie sich dabei über schulden viele
die zusammengearbeitet haben mit china
haben ja genau diese erfahrung gemacht
und da will man hier die lehre
vermitteln es ist nicht gut wenn man
sich in die abhängigkeit von autoritären
staaten begibt das erleben ja eigentlich
auch die europäer gerade
aber es kommt natürlich am ende darauf
an dass diesen worten auch ganz schnell
taten folgen damit eben diese
schwellenländer die heute hier waren am
ende lieber mit den g7 zusammenarbeiten
als ihre geschäfte weiter mit russland
zu machen
stichwort klimaschutz geräte auf diesem
gipfel in den hintergrund
ja einerseits jahr der ukraine krieg
sorgt ja dafür bei vielen ländern auch
bei deutschland dass man weiter erst mal
auf fossile brennstoffe setzt eben wegen
der energieknappheit aber gleichzeitig
dient ja auch ein stück weit als
katalysator weil man merkt ja wie
schlecht es ist wenn man weiterhin auf
öl und gas setzt und davon abhängig ist
also ist hier die leser schnell raus aus
diesen fossilen brennstoffen und weil es
interessant das ist heute eben die
unterzeichnung einer klima erklärung gab
man verpflichtet sich noch einmal auf
die klimaziele und die haben die fünf
gastländer eben mit unterzeichnet die g7
bieten ihnen und allen die mitmachen
wollen partnerschaften an da gibt es
dann auch wieder innovationen da gibt es
weitergabe von technologien eben um die
umstellung auf erneuerbare energien zu
schaffen oder ist alles funktioniert
natürlich nur wenn wie schon einmal
gesagt den worten auch wirklich taten
folgen
einschätzung von mrt wissen live vom g7
gipfel vielen dank
weltpolitik in krisenzeiten ausführliche
informationen zum treffen der g7 gibt es
auch gleich nach uns in einem zdf
spezial ein weiteres signal richtung
moskau kam heute von der nato einen tag
vor beginn des nato gipfels in madrid
kündigt der generalsekretär stoltenberg
an die schnelle eingreiftruppe massiv
aufzustocken und zwar von derzeit 40.000
auf weit über
300.000 soldatinnen und soldaten
franziska von tiesenhausen hat details
die nato plant einen massiven ausbau
ihrer abschreckungs und verteidigungs
kapazitäten grund dafür ist russlands
angriff auf die ukraine heute ist
gezielte generalsekretärs deutenberg
erste schritte on you kommt unser neues
konzept wird uns in einer ära des
strategischen wettbewerbs leiten ich
erwarte dass es klar macht dass das
bündnis russland
als größte und direkteste bedrohung
unserer sicherheit sieht
das bündnis plant unter anderem den
umbau der sogenannten schnellen
einsatztruppe über die die nato seit 20
jahren verfügt um im krisenfall rasch
reagieren zu können sie umfasst rund
40.000 soldatinnen und soldaten nach
russlands einmarsch in die ukraine wurde
ein teil der schnellen eingreiftruppe
erstmals verlegt unter anderem nach
rumänien künftig will die nato fast
achtmal so viele soldaten für
kurzfristige einsätze bereit halten
fragen wir noch mal nach bei florian
neumann in brüssel warum jetzt diese
massive aufstocken das hat natürlich mit
dem ganzen neuen blick auf russland zu
tun wie gehört wird man in dieser woche
im neuen strategischen konzept russland
erstmals als die größte und bedeutendste
bedrohung der nato direkt bezeichnen und
wenn das so ist hat das natürlich folgen
für die aufstellung der nato bisher galt
da die sogenannte philosophie des
stolperdraht eine vergleichsweise kleine
zahl von soldaten soll einen möglichen
russischen angriff etwas bremsen die
russischen truppen quasi stolpern lassen
das reicht jetzt nicht mehr man will
eben diese soldaten diese fast 300.000
soldaten in erhöhter alarmbereitschaft
um daraus ein ganzes sicherheitsnetz
werden zu lassen dass im ernstfall
möglichst schnell verlegt werden kann
das ganze folgt dabei der logik der
abschreckung wie wir es aus den zeiten
des kalten krieges noch kennen man
rüstet auf um damit eigentlich den
ernstfall zu verhindern es ist also vor
allem ein signal der abschreckung an
moskau aber eines das man im kreis der
nato offenbar für nötig hält danke schon
nach brüssel florian neu an
in der ukraine werden natürlich all die
zeichen des westens registriert vor
allem aber kämpfen die menschen weiter
ums überleben am nachmittag wurde ein
einkaufszentrum in der zentral ukraine
von russischen raketen getroffen es soll
mindestens zehn tote und viele verletzte
geben glück war bot
es war kurz vor 4 als die tödliche
rakete mindestens eine einschlug im
einkaufszentrum hielten sich da
annähernd 1000 menschen auf der gesamte
komplex wegen sofort in flammen auf
in den trümmern suchten verzweifelte
überlebende nach seiner familie das
einkaufszentrum liegt in der großstadt
krementschouk standort der größten
raffinerie des landes 300 kilometer
südöstlich der hauptstadt kiew es sei
zwecklos so eine erste reaktion von
präsident alan ski von russen humanes
verhalten zu erwarten die russische
armee hat seit letzter woche ihre
luftangriffe auf ziele überall in der
ukraine deutlich verstärkt oder lemberg
archiv sharif man greife nur
militärische ziele an heißt es in moskau
doch getroffen werden wie gestern in
kiew immer wieder auch wohngebäude mit
zahlreichen toten und verletzten
trotz der bedrohung nahmen die menschen
in kiew heute ihre arbeit wieder auf an
das g7-treffen knüpfen sie die
vorsichtige hoffnungen
ukraine ist ganz oben auf der
tagesordnung ich glaube sie begreifen
dass es nicht nur um uns sondern um die
zukunft europas geht
präsident salewski hat die hoffnung
geäußert dass der krieg bis zum einbruch
des winters beendet werden könnte
an der front im osten der ukraine sind
inzwischen auch deutsche
artilleriegeschütze im einsatz insgesamt
sieben panzerhaubitzen 2000 wurden
letzte woche geliefert unsere reporterin
katrin eigendorf konnte sich ein bild
machen von deren einsatz
wir müssen uns durch die büsche schlagen
die deutsche panzerhaubitze liegt
versteckt an der frontlinie im osten es
ist das erste mal dass die ukrainische
armee journalisten mit hierhin nimmt wir
mussten unsere handys ausschalten dürfen
den ort nicht nennen groß die sorge dass
die russen die position entdecken
egal in welcher armee der welt die acht
hillary ist das erste ziel für den
gegner ausschalten will denn diese
technik ist für den feind besonders
gefährlich
ein soldat zeigt mir auf seinem handy
die veraltete technik mit der sie bis
jetzt kämpfen mussten
das hier ist also die deutsche
panzerhaubitze auf die ukraine so lange
gewartet haben sie haben hier ein modell
versteckt tief unter ein gebüsch um
sie zu schützen von hier wird sie dann
an eine position gefahren von wo aus sie
feuern kann die ukraine hoffen dass sie
damit eine wende hier im krieg im osten
der ukraine erzwingen können
ruslan ist erst vor fünf tagen aus
deutschland zurückgekommen in 36 tagen
schnelldurchlauf hat er alles gelernt
technik und taktik doch kommt die
lieferung der haubitzen nicht zu spät
ich glaube es ist zu spät viel zu spät
warum wir hätten schon vor dem 24
februar vorbereitet sein sollen es war
bekannt dass die russen uns angreifen
würden sie werden uns nie in ruhe lassen
wir hätten darauf rechtzeitig
vorbereitet sein sollen
welcome to use change haben sie auf die
front geschrieben ein provokanter
willkommensgruß an die russen auch das
ist teil der kriegsführung
mit sorge blickt praktisch ganz europa
in richtung herbst und winter das gas
könnte knapp werden heute trafen sich
die für energie zuständigen minister in
luxemburg und waren sich in einem
wichtigen punkt einig die staaten müssen
sich gegenseitig helfen um die
versorgung zu sichern und um eine
wirtschaftskrise zu verhindern ina
baltes berichtet
die stimmung ist fröhlich das thema
bitter ernst die energieministerin in
luxemburg sorgen sich ums gas für die
kommenden monate den winter droht ein
szenario das tatsächlich reduktion
gesetz nicht verordnet werden müssen das
würde dann meine antike nach zu einer
schweren wirtschaftskrise in europa und
in deutschland führen das gilt es
unbedingt zu vermeiden deutschland da
ist sich der minister sicher würde gas
von nachbarn bekommen und selbst auch
helfen die gasmärkte in europa seien eng
verflochten eine versorgungskrise in
einem land führt zu einer
wirtschaftskrise im anderen land wir
sind hier auf eine solidarität
verpflichtet und angewiesen und das aber
auch der geist den ich spüre wenn ich
mit den kollegen rede wir lassen uns
nicht erpressen wir lassen uns nicht
spalten wir stehen zusammen
langfristig immerhin gibt es auch
hoffnung rumänien zweitgrößter lieferant
in der eu fördert jetzt mehr gas und
große vorkommen liegen noch tief im
schwarzen meer auch andere länder sind
zum teilen bereit größer in kroatien ist
die energiesituation recht stabil und
wir haben ein lng terminal nicht nur für
energie für uns sondern auch für die
nachbarländer
40 prozent der energie in der eu so die
minister heute soll künftig aus
erneuerbaren quellen kommen der gesamte
energieverbrauch bis 2030 um 36 prozent
sinken die beschlüsse heute ein weiteres
schrittchen richtung grünes europa
jetzt zur katholischen kirche in
deutschland dass sie in der krise steckt
ist bekannt neu ist die heute
veröffentlichte rekord zahl der
austritte schon in den vergangenen
jahren kehrten immer mehr katholiken
ihrer kirche den rücken allerdings noch
nie so viele wie 2021 was
360.000 nach neuen details in
missbrauchsfällen könnte es beobachtern
zufolge in diesem jahr sogar noch mehr
werden dort der färber
die kirchenbänke sind halbwegs gefüllt
das ist längst nicht jeden sonntag so in
der neusser heilig geist kirche auch
hier treten immer mehr menschen aus und
sie nennen dem pfarrer ganz verschiedene
gründe
es ist vor allem amt frauenfrage
missbrauch
frage von
der sexualmoral diese dinge und da sagen
sie das ist nicht mehr zeitgemäß so kann
es geschmeckt die katholische kirche
kommt aus den negativschlagzeilen nicht
heraus die schleppende missbrauchs
aufarbeitung die finanzskandale
das spiegelt sich in den austrittszahlen
da gibt es nichts schönzureden
sind sehr ernüchternde erschütternde
zahlen die höchste zahl von
kirchenaustritten die wir je verzeichnet
haben diese kirche muss sich verändern
sonst verliert sie immer mehr menschen
die katholische kirche hat mit reformen
begonnen synodaler weg nennt sich das
vielen austrittswilligen reicht das aber
nicht ein neues merken sie dass gehen
inzwischen auch menschen die sich der
kirche eng verbunden gefühlt haben es
gehen ältere und engagierte
werden immer weniger in der
gemeindearbeit wird es auch immer
weniger und in der messe auch
das ist ja in allen kirchen sorgen
zuversicht behalten wollen sie hier
dennoch und der pfarrer segnet zum
beginn der feriensaison erstmal die
fahrzeuge
auch der diesjährige friedenspreis des
deutschen buchhandels steht im zeichen
des kriegs er geht an den ukrainischen
schriftsteller und musiker serie
scheitern der 47 jährige lebt im
umkämpften kharkiv in vielen seiner
texte geht es darum wie krieg und
zerstörung das leben der ukraine prägen
seit der russischen invasion verteilt
dann vor allem hilfsgüter und rettet
menschen aus umkämpften vierteln den
preis bekommt er für beides sein
literarisches werk und sein soziales
engagement
mehr zu seriöser dann haben wir für sie
in der zdf- heute- app dort können sie
sehen warum er in der ukraine so bekannt
ist und was seine texte so besonders
macht
nach dem unwetter mit starkregen und
hagel schauen in deutschland hat es
jetzt den äußersten südwesten der
niederlande getroffen ein tornado zog am
mittag über das auch bei deutschen
urlaubern beliebte tricks sie in zeeland
hinweg ein mensch kam ums leben zehn
weitere sollen verletzt worden sein
teilten rettungsdienste mit zehn bis
zwanzig häuser seien unbewohnbar und
jetzt zur schwimm-wm mazda hat florian
wellbrock in echten lauf ja das ist
schon eine absolute spitzenleistung die
der 24 jährige da abliefert vier
wettbewerbe vier medaillen silber und
bronze im becken gestern der sieg mit
der freiwasser mixed staffel ja und
heute das zweite gold über die fünf
kilometer im lukas
11 ist unser freund mit silber an den
italiener petrini und bronze an
schwimmen kumpmann schock aus der
ukraine
florian wellbrock hat sich
freigeschwommen im freiwasser mit einer
machtdemonstration aus gold und bastelt
sich in budapest ein kleeblatt aus wm
medaillen aus silber und bronze im
becken wird nach dem sieg in der
mixed-staffel das erste einzel gold über
fünf kilometer gefeiert und gedrückt von
genau den leuten die er sich auf dem
podium gewünscht hat am mittwoch über
zehn kilometer ist favorit wellbrock
olymp der sieger und titelverteidiger
aus solchem holz sind sportler des
jahres geschnitzt
auftakt des rasentennis klassikers in
wimbledon und da hat maximilian maurer
als erster deutscher tennisprofi die
zweite runde erreicht er siegte in 13
einsätzen gegen den slowenen aljaz
bedene
nico sturm hat als fünfter deutscher in
der nfl geschichte mit seiner colorado
avalanche die nordamerikanische
eishockey meisterschaft gewonnen durch
den 22 einzig gestern abend bei tampa
bay lightning den hochheben darf ist das
eishockey hält diesen 20 kilogramm
schweren stanley cup dazu gehört auch
nico sturm der als fünfter deutscher
diesen triumph in der nhl feiern kann
den entscheidenden treffer markierte der
finger lecken zum 2 1 dem vierten erfolg
im best of seven finale vor fünf jahren
war colorado noch das schlechteste team
jetzt gewinnen sie nach 1996 und 2001
zum dritten mal und entrollen damit
titelverteidiger tampa bay lightning
20 kilo schwer das ding allerhand
dankeschön norbert der deutsche
wetterdienst warnt aktuell vor schweren
gewittern mit starkregen im südlichen
bayern und auch in der nacht bleibt es
unruhig mehr dazu gleich von ostend ali
marietta slomka begrüßt sie um viertel
vor zehn im heute-journal wir wünschen
ihnen noch einen schönen abend was
machen wenn sie mit auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter wir haben es mit
diesen tief der zeit zu tun dazu gehört
diese kaltfront die löst halber so
unwetter aus in den nächsten stunden
morgen setzt sich dann vorübergehend
dieses kleine hochfest und da wird es im
norden deutschlands relativ ruhig aber
wiederum mit dem tief über norditalien
wo recht viel regen dabei ist kommen
dann auch schauer und gewitter über die
alpen zu uns schauen uns das ganze im
detail an in den nächsten stunden
heftige gewitter von den alpen bis
bayerischer wald bis ins erzgebirge und
in diesem rot schraffierten bereich kann
es teilweise größeren hagel geben auch
starkregen also viel regnen kurze zeit
sturm und orkanböen all das ist möglich
über nacht ansonsten im westen lockert
es auf bei temperaturen von 19 grad im
osten und 8 grad ganz im westen morgen
also letzte schauer im erzgebirge zieht
ab im süden neue schauer und gewitter
mit dem tief aus dem süden sonst gibt es
viel sonnenschein die höchsten
temperaturen dazu bis 28 grad nicht mehr
ganz so heiß die nächsten tage am
mittwoch weitere schauer und gewitter
bis 28 donnerstag bis 31 grad heiße ein
schöner abend